[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département et ce mercredi avec 15
mars parole à françois lasserre auteur
de plusieurs ouvrages sur les insectes
et qui sort ce mois ci un nouveau livre
pour contrer de nombreuses idées reçues
et répondre aux interrogations des
enfants un nouvel ouvrage aux noms
évocateurs les petites bêtes qui font
peur mais pas trop paroles aussi dans
cette émission à fabien parmentier qui
participe ce week-end à la 10e édition
de l'eco trail et c'est pour lui un 10
sur 10 puisqu'il s'agit de sa dixième
participation à la course éco
responsables dont le départ sera donné
une nouvelle fois à la base de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
non on débute donc avec vous cette
émission françois lasserre bonsoir
bonsoir françois lasserre vous êtes
enseignant vice-président de l'opi
notamment l'office pour les insectes et
leur environnement spécialiste de la
biodiversité et donc auteur de nombreux
ouvrages sur les insectes dont ce
nouveau nouvel ouvrage qui paraît ce
mois ci les petites bêtes qui font peur
mais pas trop on voit le nom à l'écran
un livre en résumé où les parents
trouvent la réponse à toutes les
questions que les enfants se posent pour
la génèse de ce livre est parti du
constat qu'en fait les parents étaient
un peu désarçonné faso aux questions des
plus jeunes c'est une expérience aussi
peut-être personnel c'est sûr que quand
on s'intéresse à la nature et en
particulier aux insectes ou aux
araignées on se rend compte que tout le
monde est un peu démuni en a pas on
n'apprend pas grand chose donc c'est un
bouquin qui s'adresse un peu aux parents
beaucoup aux enfants dans toute la
famille mais c'est quand même au départ
50 antisèches pour parents en détresse
paris c'est pour les parents c'est pour
les grands parents c'est pour tout le
monde puisque finalement aussi si les
enfants ont peur c'est que les parents
aussi
on va dire transmettre cette peur des
insectes est exactement alors c'est vrai
que sous couvert de répondre aux
questions des parents s'adressent à
toute la famille y compris aux enfants
mais c'est vraiment un livre familiale
ça partait de questions qui étaient
envoyés à la salamandre la salamandre
c'est l'éditeur et qui était aussi une
revue et il y avait des questions des
lecteurs et qui revêt ya plein de
questions qui reviennent souvent donc
la salamandre a décidé de compiler un
petit peu tout ça et j'ai eu comme je
connais mieux les petites dettes qui
font peur je m'occupe de celui qui fonde
et qui concerne les petites bêtes qui
font peur alors justement on va prendre
quelques exemples un des cas concrets
qui sont présents dans ce livre
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on dit un
enfant qui par exemple se demande si en
touche à en touchant un crapaud il peut
attraper des boutons c'est sérieux mais
alors qu'est-ce qu'on lui répond est-ce
qu'on peut attraper des boutons
lorsqu'on touche un crapaud alors déjà
ce qui serait bien c'est à chaque fois
qu'un enfant vous poser une question sur
la nature et que vous ne savez pas
répondu dites stop je ne sais pas mais
vous ne répondez pas ce que vous avez
toujours entendu puisque en général sur
plein de sujets mais surtout sur la
nature tout tout ce qu'on nous a raconté
c'est un peu n'importe quoi
et donc on colporte des idées reçues
comme le fait que si on touche un
crapaud m'attraper des boutons des
verrues alors c'est vrai pour les
sorcières les a trempées peut-être des
capots des boutons des mary mais pas du
tout parce que pas du tout chez les
humains nous on a la peau suffisamment
étrange pour rien attrapé du tout c'est
un petit venin qui va plutôt servir à
éloigner les prédateurs ou en tout cas
un prédateur qui loupe qui goûte un
crapaud bas il va quasiment être malade
voir vomir mais tant que c'est sur notre
peau il se passe rien le seul truc qu'on
va demander aux enfants c'est de se
laver les mains après avoir tripoté mais
avec délicatement un crapaud parce que
c'est complètement interdite puisque
c'est des animaux protégés par la loi on
n'a pas le sas une autre information
qu'on trouve aussi dans le livre tout à
fait c'est précisé c'est vrai qu'on
rappelle que c'est complètement
interdites ou chez un crapaud une
grenouille
mais c'est vrai aussi que les enfants
voilà on les laisse fait en général on
se rince les doigts c'est simplement
parce que si on se frotte l'oeil juste
après une muqueuse on peut avoir l'oeil
un petit peu irrité mais ce serait pas
très grave alors vous avez fait de
l'humour avec les sorcières mais c'est
tout au long du livre le mucha ça à sa
place important de se parler de ces
sujets là avec on va dire le sourire aux
enfants pas trop dramatiser la chose
j'essaye en tout cas je sais à quel
point tout le monde voilà en ville
surtout les urbains on est de plus en
plus éloignés des animaux etc
donc je sais à quel point on les aime
pas trop donc j'essaie de mettre au
moins au niveau tout le monde est
partant et demi les insectes et ne sont
pas nos ennemis jeu j'essaie de le faire
de façon extrêmement détendu parce que
je sais vraiment très sincèrement à quel
point
gens connaissent mal les petites bêtes
donc inutile de partir de très haut on
peut commencer par un peu d'humour et
des petites informations c'est c'est en
fait une clé d'entrée pour les regarder
autrement alors autre interrogation
là j'en suis sûr concerne beaucoup de
monde peut-on avaler une mariée en
dormant la nuit ça je suis sûr que tous
on le pense alors j'espère que non que
moi ne le pense pas en fait je les mises
parce que c'est celle là ça fait plutôt
partie des légendes urbaines parce qu'il
ya les idées reçues qui sombrait en
général à moitié vrai moitié fausse
plutôt fausses
et puis aller les gens du remède des
trucs qui peuvent pas arriver donc sur
les araignées alors les uns les
araignées elles prennent tous quasiment
alors sont pas des insectes mais c'est
pas grave ce sont des arachnides mais
elles prennent vraiment où tous nous
tous nos fantasmes toutes nos idées
reçues y compris les légendes urbaines
ont dit les araignées pendent sous la
peau qui a des petits bébés araignées
qui sortent de la peau quand on gratte
le bouton ce qui est archifaux on dit
qu'on peut en manger la nuit quand on
dort ce qui est archifaux aussi et puis
dans les idées reçues en fait une
araignée au regain d'intérêt ce serait
vraiment une araignée suicidaire quoi
c'est un grand un conduit chaud humide
la ventilation ça sent l'homme de
partout où il a régné n'a rien à faire
dans une bouche est d'ailleurs
l'araignée a rien à faire parfois elle
peut se balader sur le lit mais c'est en
général un garçon qui cherche une fille
puisque c'est un peu le seul moment où
les araignées se baladent les grosses
araignées des maisons se balade dans la
dans la maison c'est au moment où les
gars on cherche une fille pour
s'accoupler alors dernière question sur
ce livre parce que on le prend avec
sourire et elle le mouron l'elysée mais
aussi une vraie réflexion derrière sur
sur la vie de ces êtres vivants on a
souvent tendance à écraser les araignées
les moustiques vous est-ce que vous
souhaitez aussi que vos lecteurs que ce
soient les plus petits et les plus
grands réfléchissent là dessus ça c'est
vraiment et l'éditeur vraiment m'a
incité à faire ça mais c'est vraiment un
de mes trucs c'est que de rappeler qu on
n'est pas les seuls sur terre on est
entouré de
millions d'êtres vivants les petites
bêtes sont les plus nombreuses
et à force de dire pas chez moi mais
chez le voisin belle si le voisin n'en
veut pas tout ces animaux n'ont plus
d'endroit où vivre sur terre on est
quasiment partout donc les animaux non
humains n'ont plus leur place chez nous
donc c'est une façon de le dire écouter
essayer de vous détendre de les regarder
différemment de les accueillir n'a
aucune dangereuse en france vous pouvez
très bien éventuellement à émerger les
scénarios tranquille chez vous elle va
pas vous piquez contrairement à ce qu'on
vous raconte les araignées pique pas ou
mortes pas et donc c'est vraiment une
invitation à laisser les animaux non
humains un peu tranquille sur le balcon
pourquoi pas dans la maison en tout cas
sur le balcon et dans le jardin à 100%
merci françois lasserre pour toutes ces
informations et donc pour les intéressés
et on trouve votre ouvrage aux éditions
salamandre la salamandre
merci on continue ce site 8 les invite
avec notre deuxième invité fabien
parmentier bonsoir bonsoir d'ailleurs
fabien apparemment tirés pour rebondir
sur ce qu'on vient dire 'est-ce que vous
qui êtes un habitué de la nature puisque
vous faites notamment l'eco trail de
paris est ce que vous avez peur des
petites bêtes
j'imagine que non j'ai pas forcément
peur des petites bêtes mais justement
j'essaie de pas mettre les pieds
n'importe où sur les chemins pour les
préserver quoi alors vous n'êtes pas ici
évidemment vous reparler de ce livre
mais vous participé ce week-end à la
dixième participation d'u10 et de l'eco
trail une course qui rallie la base de
loisirs de saint quentin divine à la
tour eiffel notamment 80 km j'allais
vous demandez en première question si
vous êtes prêt pour une telle course
mais j'ai déjà la réponse est oui
puisque c'est la dixième fois que vous
le faites et à chaque fois vous avez
fini la course dans les délais impartis
est ce que il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
pour vous pour ce week-end voilà trop
n'y a pas forcément d'inquiétude ans
alors je vais aborder comme la course
toujours avec la même la même humilité
en c'est le cas tous les ans alors déjà
l'arrivée aller à la tour eiffel mais il
faut bien préciser qu'elle est au
premier étage de la tour eiffel
c'est à dire qu'à la fin après avoir
couru de 80km faut monter trois cents
300 et quelques marches sinon ce serait
un peu trop facile qu'en fait quand on
arrive à la tour eiffel on croit que
c'est fini mais en fait c'est fini mais
l'arrivée de la ligne d'arrivée elle est
réellement là ou quoi donc voilà après
effectivement je capitalise sur mais mes
neuf premières
participation donc à l'eco-trail pour
aborder cette 10e bon je suis assez
confiant parce que je connais un petit
peu le parcours maintenant puis je
commence a aussi mieux vous connaître
donc côté physiquement quand et côté
physique côté moral voilà je sais un peu
plus à quoi m'attendre 1 malgré tout
dites nous comment on se prépare pour
parcourir 80 km environ huit heures je
crois à 8h30 pour vous 30
voilà pour moi à 8h30 sur les notamment
les deux dernières éditions sachant que
les premières étaient un peu moins la
première vous y ait 10 heures un peu
plus de dix heures j'ai commencé vers
10h30 voilà senna veut faire 80 km peu
de monde pense être incapable de le
faire mais je pense que ça mérite
ils méritent comme à la plage de se
reposer la question mais voilà on
s'improvise pas en fait sur une course
de cet ordre là on progresse avec le
temps moi je me suis pas mis à courir
même si c'est parti d'un pari avec un
collègue pour courir la première édition
le jour de mes 30 ans j'ai commencé
comme beaucoup par faire du petit
jogging
en revanche j'ai un passé de footballeur
mais faire des petits jogging après j'ai
voilà je suis passé par le paris
versailles notamment la course le paris
versailles après j'ai fait quelques
marathons et un jour je me suis lancé
effectivement après un bep de paris avec
un collègue sur cette édition le jour de
mes 30 ans et à quelques jours de la
course vous pourrez par exemple tous les
jours j'ai région aujourd'hui combien de
kilomètres
malheureusement non chez un mauvais
élève en fait la cour très courageux
courtrai bel effet sur 10 ans envoyé sur
l'eau dce au niveau des systèmes à des
présentations mais au niveau de
l'entraînement blanche est un mauvais
élève
je vis pas mal sûr mais à qui j'ai la
chance de ne pas forcément beaucoup
m'entraîner là je reviens du ski
justement j'ai pas couru depuis
depuis depuis plus de quinze jours après
je récupère très vite aussi et puis donc
j'ai un géant un bon foncier ce qui nous
permet d'aborder quand même ce genre
d'épreuve assez sereinement même si j'ai
pas forcément couru de toute manière on
se préserve avant la dernière semaine on
se préserve beaucoup
très peu de personnes vont courir juste
avant la course quelles sont les
particularités d'une telle course et 90%
sur sur des sentiers j'imagine que
le volet psychologique et ultra
important au delà aussi du volet
physique voilà il ya c'est ce que j'ai
appris moi durant ses neuf premières
éditions je me sers quand même deux sets
comment dire de l'eco trail notamment
pour pour aborder d'autres courses
encore plus difficile que ce soit en
montagne par exemple mais il ya un gros
foley un gros volet pardon physique
effectivement ça demande de
l'entraînement une musculation qui est
qu'ils soient adaptés à ce genre de
d'efforts mais aussi un gros volet
mentale parce qu'effectivement il faut
être capable de tenir la distance sur un
double marathon en l'occurrence donc on
passe par plusieurs par plusieurs phases
évidemment très mental voilà il ya des
moments d'euphorie c'est ce que beaucoup
cherchent aussi où on cherche à
atteindre dans le running des moments
d'euphorie
et puis des moments des moments très
durs après faut savoir effectivement
qu'à chaque à chaque moment où c'est
justement on est un peu dans le creux
c'est comme après la pluie vient le beau
temps il ya quand même toujours des
moments où on sent beaucoup mieux
notamment quand on franchit la ligne
d'arrivée
alors pour parler souvenir puisque c'est
votre dixième participation vous une
fois vous avez couru vous étiez malade
et en l'espace de 80 kilomètres vous
avez perdu 6 kilos en l'espace
c'est à dire que j'avais vraiment mal
préparé cette course là en plus
clairement je m'étais très mal hydrater
faut savoir que pour des efforts comme
ça l'hydratation c est prépondérant donc
effectivement j'avais loupé mon
hydratation toute la semaine précédent
j'avais quasiment pas forcément dû
beaucoup d'eau pas forcément bio de
choses mais j'ai loupé mon hydratation
comme il fallait les trois jours avant
effectivement je les payais le jour j et
et on va dire sur les 30 derniers
kilomètres j'ai eu beaucoup de mal et
puis mon corps m'a un petit peu rappelé
à l'ordre
et effectivement côté j'ai perdu des
kilos parce qu'effectivement j'ai été
malade pendant la course
c'est pas ce dont je suis plus glorieux
mais mais après voilà le mentalement ça
m'a permis de tenir aussi jusqu'au bout
et voilà un mot pour terminer sur la
partie environnementale de cette course
puisque c'est un eco trail
courez sur des sentiers dans la nature
vous n'avez pas le droit je crois plus
gobelet en plastique excusez moi un
repas individuel il ya un vrai volet
loisirs et environnemental c'est quelque
chose qui vous attire aussi dans cette
course
oui tout à fait quand on aborde le trail
de toute manière c'est valable ceci sur
les courses en pleine nature donc pas en
région parisienne mais en montagne
effectivement il ya un volet en courant
en semi autonomie c'est à dire qu'en
fait on même s'il ya des ravitaillements
à différents points de la course
on est censé être semi autonome
effectivement semi autonome notamment
ainsi que le matériel notamment on est
appelé à apporter nous mêmes notre
gobelet lorsqu'on arrive son
ravitaillement pour prendre du coca de
l'eau ou autre et le but du jeu c'est
effectivement tous les petits déchets
qu'on peut être amené à créer pendant la
course des barres 2d papier de barres 2d
barres énergétiques des choses comme ça
l'idée c'est quand même de les garder
sur soi on a des petits sachets qui ne
sont distribués pouvoir les les garder
sur nous et puis les déposer au prochain
ravitaillement dans des poubelles dans
les poubelles pardon merci femme voilà
parmentier d'être venu en plateau et
puis plus d'informations sur les côtes
règles sur www.tradeshownews.com merci à
vous d'être venu en plateau pour vos
réponses c'est la fin du set 8 les
invités pour ce soir prochain rendez
vous demain bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]